le modèle qui en tout cas le le modèle
qui est en tête c'est celui qui existe
de manière le plus répandue dans le
monde
occidental en matière d'organisation du
contrôle de la Sûreté Nucléaire et
d'aracho-protection ou finalement
l'expertise et le contrôle et la
décision sont intégrés dans une même
organisation c'est le cas aux États-Unis
c'est le cas au Canada c'est le cas au
Japon donc nous ne sommes pas en train
d'inventer un modèle nous sommes en
train de de regarder les meilleures
pratiques internationales pour pouvoir
nous interroger nous-mêmes tout va c'est
le gouvernement qui est posé cette
question sur la manière de faire évoluer
le système pour leur plus robuste plus
efficace et adapté aux enjeux sans
précédent face auxquels nous allons nous
trouver pas pendant les deux ou trois
prochaines années mais pendant plusieurs
décennies la nouvelle impulsion qui sont
prises en matière de politique
énergétique vont conduire à des charges
de travail et à des impulsions qui vont
durer plusieurs dizaines d'années donc
c'est une décision importante à un
moment qui va produire des effets qui
produira des effets sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années lorsque l'on parle de
construction de problèmes
électronucléaires se sont en
interacteurs qui vont durer 60 ans ils
vont être construits sur une période de
plusieurs dizaines d'années et quand on
parle de poursuite d'exploitation des
réacteurs actuels on ne s'interroge sur
60 ans au-delà de 60 ans ça veut dire
pour les réacteurs les plus récents plus
de 40 ans encore de durée de vie donc
voyez-vous on est dans un une
perspective historique d'organisation du
contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection qui va durer longtemps
et qui doit être prise à un moment où
cette impulsion est organisée